speaking of style we can expect many
major sound moments from Demi Lovato on
her tell me you love me tour that's
hitting North America and only et scored
an exclusive in life
[Applause]
guys we're hanging backstage with Demi
Lovato on her brand-new tour being
confident so how many custom changes do
we have I have seven votes and four hair
changes I mean we share at this point
that's what I'm doing when I run off
stage I'm like underneath the stage
trying to change for the next out but I
was like ripping it off and taking off
my clothes getting the guys under the
stage every show fabulous Demi's doing
20 cities and 34 days on her tell me you
love me tour along for the ride dj
khaled and Kalani all right let's have a
little fun one thing that each one of
you had to remember to bring on the road
with you my dog oh my god mine too
Oh can they be friends yes they can be
friends Batman and Cinderella are mine
okay face time to see my son
oh yes yes you go come on go come on
stage two I didn't ask you but I'm gonna
make this is where all the chaos happens
during the show everyone's running
around screaming
Demi's choreographer took me into what
they called the underworld and showed me
all the costumes so this is the costume
change they say they can do in 20
seconds I have my timer
[Music]
27 seconds for the costume
[Music]